[Musique]
c'est un challenge collectif national
lancé depuis 2016
c'est une initiative du ministère des
solidarités et de la santé en
partenariat avec l'assurance maladie et
santé publique france donc voilà ce
challenge et invite toutes les personnes
qui le souhaitent à arrêter de fumer
pendant un mois tous ensemble à moi
c'est cinq fois plus de chances de
réussir son sevrage tabagique par la
suite si il y avait éventuellement
embauches chutent au moins si vous vous
aurez pu prendre conscience que vous
êtes capable de vaud de vous passer de
certaines cigarettes ou de toutes les
cigarettes donc plus de réussite pour
une prochaine tentative
ce qu'on a pu constater lors du premier
confinement c'est que ça aussi et est
une période propice aux changements de
comportements individuels
nous avons fort à parier que toute la
solidarité et les encouragements au
quotidien par exemple sur la communauté
facebook n'en seront que plus présent et
renforcer cette année donc profitez-en
pour aller trouver toute la motivation
et le soutien dont vous avez besoin